[Music]
hello and welcome back
our final panel this morning
is going to explore how the uk can
maximize its position
as a potential world leader in science
research and the development of vaccines
you can ask a question of my panelists
who i'll be
introducing you to in just a moment
by writing in the text box at the bottom
of the screen
or by emailing events at spectator
dot co dot uk no doubt at all that the
uk
leads europe in the early stage clinical
research for new
vaccines and medicines as well as
research into
heart disease and indeed the medical
research sector has brought in over 300
million pounds in income to the nhs
last year but in the covid19 era
even the best has proven not to be
enough
despite fantastic work between some of
our finest universities
and big pharma and also other things
people
far apart ranging from dyson to
mercedes f1 coming up and helping with
work on ventilators
extraordinary imagination unexpected
offers of help came
in thick and fast but as we move
towards a period where the current range
of vaccination may just give us some
time for reflection can we do better
should we have been able to do better
there's also the added issue of
artificial intelligence huge
breakthrough
uh quite recently on that front as well
but it offers an enormous range of
possibilities for improving
the health sector we have one of the
best tech sectors in europe uh
with each area developing technologies
medicines and the rest of it and even
a basic example an algorithm from
university college hospital
could eliminate skipped appointments
it's not just high-tech brilliant stuff
it's
absolutely fundamental logistics and
that would save
a billion pounds every year money that
could of course be spent
on vaccine initiatives and the rest of
it
but and it's a real problem much of the
nhs is still stuck
using windows 7 so as brilliant men and
women come up with brilliant ideas there
are some
pretty fundamental things that need
sorting out as well
if we are to make real progress to help
me discuss
uh and reflect upon those issues and i'm
sure others i'm delighted to say
i have lord o'shaughnessy uh who is a
former health minister himself
uh tina woods who is the founder of
collider health
uh catherine williams who's the business
unit director at msd there are sponsors
uh this morning and also matt whitty
chief executive
of nhs accelerated access uh
collaborative
um james i'm gonna start with you if i
if i may call you james uh lordo sean i
see
um the government's been very proactive
on this going back to the life sciences
industry strategy
uh right through to the uk vaccine
network you're now out of government
uh but in a perfect position to reflect
upon it
how stands the united kingdom in this
area
uh in your view well thank you alison
the
incredibly important topic and couldn't
be more timely i i think of it in
i suppose broadly speaking in in two
ways the challenges we face and the
opportunities that we have
um the challenges come from the fact
that
as you know the covid uh experience has
and is revealing that our greatest
strengths lie
in our basic science base our amazing
research unit
at universities um the uh
genomics assets that we have and
and and that kind of level of research
and you see that i think really
critically in two ways firstly the
recovery trial which discovered the
first
effective therapeutic for covid first in
the world and
that was a discovery and the fact that
we're one of the few countries that has
actually generated its own
new vaccine so that is that is what
we're good at
and and we've demonstrated that during
the crisis
however we can't even rest on that
particular laurel because there are two
big pressure points i think that come to
bear uh on that
our greatest strength in the basic
science the first is the fiscal
environment
it is just as we know from the most
recent budget
a difficult time to find funding for
research the medical
research charities for example are going
to have a massive hit
this year and yet as a country we know
that we actually under invest in r d
and we want to go from where we are
today which is about 1.7
of our economy spent on r d to 2.4 and
then 3
and we're going to have to do that in
the teeth of a big economic recovery
and borrowing like we never have before
the second um
threat if you like to our strength is it
comes from brexit and i don't mean that
as an
anti-brexit point at all um but simply
that we are changing
uh our regulatory system is changing we
are going to have access to
in different ways to the kind of people
that we want to attract here to do
the uh to do research and so that's
something that we are going to have to
keep an eye on
the big opportunity however though is to
address i guess what's our biggest
structural challenge which is
we're great at ideation we're great at
creation the early stage stuff
what we don't do well and this is of
course what matt does is his bread and
butter
these days is to scale up is to actually
take those great ideas
and take them to scale although during
covid we have done that through things
like dexamethasone
and other discoveries so our big
opportunity if you like is just is to
take
the good ideation early stage innovation
and scale that all the way up with a
really innovative
regulator through our fantastic tech
sector
through the fact we have this amazing
data in the health service which
gives companies like msd and others the
opportunity
to see how their medicines are working
for whom they work best
and then to take that information around
the world
and so that they can spread their
medicines because they know they have
been shown to work in
one of the best health systems in the
world james thank you very
much indeed um uh i i told matt's head
nodding up and down on several occasions
and and and also tina as well
but let me come to you first matt and uh
and put a variant of the same question i
put to james o'shaughnessy there
and just reminding folk that you're the
chief executive nhs accelerated access
collaborative
which is something that didn't exist
five years ago
so you've had not only the early years
experience but you've had the kovid 19
situation to go through and much has
been asked of you
some of it's gone better than some other
things and there's been the whole
argument about the
track and trace happen the inside work
that was done by the nhs and what have
you
but how do you feel that we stand now as
we
look at some hope uh post the vaccine
uh campaign how fairs the uk
uh in terms of science
life sciences technology and integration
uh thanks alastair and uh just to just
say i completely agree with what uh
what laura shaunicy was saying about the
uh the challenges that we faced and the
opportunities um the uk is exceptionally
well placed to capitalize
on the assets that we've got that uh the
lord oshawa see
covered and we have got world-leading um
research infrastructure
world-leading academic institutions and
as lord shawnee says
the difficult part is not creating the
ideas it's getting them adopted
at scale and this is something that
we've seen in our joint work with
uh regulatory bodies such as the care
quality commission we just do not see
an issue with frontline staff managers
coming up with
innovative solutions it's actually how
can you
adopt those solutions and how can you
adopt solutions that weren't developed
in the particular institute in which you
work that's that's that's the that's the
hard part
and at the accelerated access
collaborative we've got a range of
programs but
ultimately they're all looking to do um
the same thing which is to get the best
treatments to to patients faster
and one of the uh one of the areas that
we're going to talk about a little in a
little bit more detail later is around
artificial intelligence
and we really see this as um something
that the uk
can differentiate itself from from other
countries um
we have launched jointly with um nhsx
who lead on digital strategy for the nhs
and a programme of work that will look
at um
all of the different facets about
adopting um artificial intel
intelligence into the nhs
so this includes um regulatory change
which is under the banner of something
called the
nhs artificial intelligence lab and
that's working with regulators
to um declutter the regulatory pathway
but still maintain those important
safeguards around ethics and patient
et cetera but to do that in a way that
actually doesn't get in the way of
getting these technologies to patients
as well as looking at complicated areas
like post-market surveillance for these
technologies
we're also directly funding technologies
through the ai
and health and care award so we've
announced 42
winners in the first round and the
second round is open and closes tomorrow
so quick plug for that
um but again this is looking at
technologies right from sort of early
stage where they may just need
clinical uh validation or testing
through to
prototyping right through to
technologies which have already got
and demonstrated their value in real
world settings and already
used nhs which has your role map
changed fundamentally in the light of
the last nine months in this sense
that i'm seeing seeing you as a kind of
ring master as it were
but work may be done by oxford
university or southampton university
all work may be done by msd and
if it's happening at a university then
they need a commercial partner
if it's happening in the commercial
sector maybe they could get some help
with the university side and so on and
so forth has that
ringmaster role changed fundamentally in
the last nine months uh
everything has changed fundamentally in
the last five months including uh
including my role
and but you touched on it you touched on
a great point there and i think that one
of the
key areas that we have worked on and
actually it's one of the areas where
kobet has accelerated our work
so one of the key things that we were
looking to do um was to get a better
view about what technologies are coming
through and get a joined up view across
ourselves across the
across nice across uh different
different arms like body uh institutions
together about what's coming through
where are the gaps and where do we need
to intervene at
a level and one of the key things that
we've been able to do during kobe is
accelerate that process
so that for the three technologies that
uh so for
rendezvir and for the two steroids that
the recovery trial looked at
we put in place a system where we were
scanning um
for what research was being undertaken
and we were
linking up that the outputs of that work
into the medicines and healthcare
regulatory authority to see whether what
licensing changes were needed
we were going back to the national
institute for health research to look at
to make sure that
the exact uh research questions the
correct research questions were being
looked at
and the upshot of that was that when
that when those studies read out
there was guidance and they were those
treatments were available on the nhs
within hours i mean that is
these things take months or years
sometimes has your role
matt changed fundamentally in the light
of the last nine months in this sense
that i'm seeing seeing you as a kind of
ring master as it were
but work may be done by oxford
university or southampton university
all work may be done by msd and
if it's happening at a university then
they need a commercial partner
if it's happening in the commercial
sector maybe they could get some help
with the university side and so on and
so forth has that
ringmaster role changed fundamentally in
the last nine months
eventually in the last five months
including uh including my role
and but you touch on you touch on a
great point there and i think that one
of the key areas that we have worked on
and actually
it's one of the areas where kobe has
accelerated our work so one of the key
things that we were looking to do
um was to get a better view about what
technologies are coming through and get
a joined up view across ourselves across
the across nice across different
different
arms like body institutions together
about what's coming through where are
the gaps and where do we need to
intervene
at a level and one of the key things
that we've been able to do during cobie
is accelerate that process
so that for the three technologies that
uh so for
uh rem december and for the two steroids
that the recovery trial looked at
we put in place a system where we were
scanning um
for what research was being undertaken
and we were
linking up that the output of that work
into the medicines and healthcare
regulatory authority to see whether what
licensing changes were needed
we were going back to the national
institute for health research to look at
to make sure that
the exact uh research questions the
correct research questions were being
looked at
and the upshot of that was that when
that when those studies read out
there was guidance and they were those
treatments were available on the nhs
within hours i mean
that is these things take months or
years sometimes so
covered 19 accelerated it significantly
and i'm grateful for that tina woods
founder of collider health
um have they bought a new skill set to
the party
what's your take on how the uk life
sciences sit at the moment and the
relationship between
as it were government academia and
industry you're at the pounding heart of
that
what's your take first of all i i just
want to make the point that what covet
has shown
us um despite you know our strengths and
science and our nhs
we are actually an incredibly unhealthy
nation
so i think we really need to see
everything that we do ahead to this lens
of building up resilience
uh building up our health to not only
cover but future pandemic threats as
well
so um so i uh we know uh britain has an
incredible tech ecosystem life sciences
industry we've talked about
difficulties in translation i do a lot
of work with the academic health science
networks
matt mentioned nhs ai lab i do work with
them as well
and uk research and innovation so
they're very very keen on harnessing
us you know the invention the ideas from
britain and translating them into
commercial success
which other countries do better than us
like the us for example
um but uh the reality is uh it's you
know data is at the heart of this and of
course i
am fascinated and very interested in
data
i do a lot of work in ai and data
through my work and i've just written
about in my book live longer with ai
but and we talk about data as being the
most valuable um
acid on earth which only gets more
valuable the more it's connected unlike
oil
which gets depleted the more you use it
so while data can drive and of course
the uk government recognizes this that
data can drive new capabilities
industries jobs economic growth
but the reality is and this is one of
the big problems is that you need data
in a format that can be read by machines
which is what you need to apply
artificial intelligence so i do a lot of
work
in ai so a lot of our health data is not
digitized
it's in primary care yes but not in
hospitals where a lot of it is still on
paper
to really leverage data we need data
that is fair what i mean by fair is
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable
um and that is a tall order for data at
the moment and that's our big trouble at
the moment it's locked in drawers
on patient bedsides and locked within
institutions that
in many ways don't have an incentive to
share because data is power and control
you only have to look at the big giants
to know that
but we're also obsessed and i'm being a
bit more taking a bit more of a
destructive view here we're also
obsessed with data in the health care
system
look at what we are faced with as a
nation our unhealthy nation
um this is sick data data in our health
care system
if you look at the determinants of
health most of it sits outside health
healthcare
it's our social circumstance our
education our
poverty uh it's genomics which is a
massive area so these are actually
very very important data sets which need
far more attention
we therefore need to broaden the view of
data to encompass the wider determinants
of our health
look at our unhealthy nation at the
moment we've been
very impacted by covert the big
opportunity going back to ai
is finding patterns in very large data
sets in healthy domains
the most important data to look at if
you're interested in keeping people
healthy and well
and to build resilience to covert and
future pandemic threats
and the potential of ai and multimodal
ai and
machine learning is to develop predicted
and preventative
health strategies and it's a colossal
opportunity harnessing data from
genetics biological behavioral financial
data
life data so i will close with this the
big opportunity that i feel
for britain to lead into space and maybe
in another moonshot initiative
is getting device to learn think and
work together produce
novel insights in terms of keeping us
healthy and well there are billions of
petabytes of data flowing through ai
devices every day
and the volume will only get increased
in the years to come with
5g edge and quantum computing etc this
is a big focus of some of the work that
james and i are doing with the all-party
parliamentary for longevity
we've got to do more to a healthy and
healthy nation that we are faced with
thank you very much indeed absolutely
intriguing um
bits of that i will come back to in a
moment uh as well
um that are just getting to complete my
general picture
uh of of how things stand um and i'm
delighted that catherine williams
business unit director msd our sponsors
this morning is with us as well
catherine what i'm looking for there to
build on what james shawnee said about
the commitment of the government and the
lessons that have been learned
matt talking about the nhs frontline
experience and that key relationship
between
the academic world and people like you
in the in the commercial developmental
sector as well
and tina with all of the data in the
background how better and quicker and
faster we can do things
in future what's your snapshot on that
crucial relationship between
the scientific sector and
and government uh and the civil service
including the nhs in that sense are we
in a good place i think we are in a good
place and and i guess before i answer
that i just want to say that
we're delighted to be part of this
conversation and supporting and
sponsoring the summit today
i think the key part that i'd reflect
alistair is the coordination
between government between the health
service between
industries life hours third sector
academia
it's going to be critical if we're going
to bring these novel ideas forward and
drive
system change we've seen this year the
unprecedented challenge that and the
pandemic has
brought to us and it has necessa
necessitated even
a global response but one that has been
coordinated across
the health and science community and
as msd we're proud to be part of that
community
and not just ensuring that we deliver
medicines and vaccines through the
pandemic but also that we're part of the
research
and scientific sector working around the
clock
to develop medicines and vaccines that
will help treat
coping 19. i know obviously the focus of
this is very much on
vaccines and i don't think there's any
doubting that in the last 50 years
vaccines have saved more lives
than any other medical procedure or
process
and so what we've seen through this
pandemic is that there's a real
opportunity for us to continue to build
on
through novel ideas whether it's the
data whether it's the system
our world leading status uh in
immunization and i think that's really
important that we continue to work
together to make sure
we're driving those system improvements
but also
we're continuing to invest we have the
right access pathways so that we are
bit the future there is no predicting
when the next pandemic will come and
where it will come from and so i think
that collaboration
that investment in science clinical
research and manufacturing to make sure
that we continue
to grow our position as a leader will
help protect us against those future
pandemics
let me stick with you for a moment on
that catherine because intriguing point
you mentioned vaccines and obviously
that that is at the pounding heart of
where we are
because of concerns over cavity 19 and
and
um the work that that so many of you in
in your sector have done and done quite
brilliantly
but looking at that general relationship
between uh the private sector and
and government um do you believe that it
requires
fine-tuning because the idea of
of of the trust between government on
behalf of the taxpayer and the private
sector
tough questions asked about profit
levels pricing levels
delivery efficiency and so on and so
forth do you believe that that
relationship is in a better place now
uh than it was before covered 19 or that
it's ever been
or that it's still a work in progress
and hmg
could do better i do believe that it's
in a better place than
it's ever been um but as with anything
we
we've learned a lot this year and we can
always do better
so i think the important thing that
whether part of government
part of the private sector whichever
that we take a moment to stand back and
reflect on the things that we've learned
this year
and how we can improve that relationship
so that we are in a better place to
continue to fight kobe 19 because we're
by no means out of the woods yet
but also that we're protecting our
population
for any future pandemics that we may be
faced with and inevitably
with the growth of infectious diseases i
think that's something that we've got to
face up to as a reality
that there will be things that we need
to work together collaboratively on in
the future to to help prevent
those infectious diseases and support
our population
thank you for that absolutely crucial um
let me bring james uh
back in as well and and
when i was reading up on this and and
preparing for our conversation this
morning
um that i was reminded of as it were the
aviation industry my father's in the
royal air force and and
classic examples like the tsr-2 where
brilliant british boffins can come up
with absolutely fantastic ideas
kind of get halfway through the research
and development level and then the
americans come in and take over
um and we sit there on the wings
um it seems to me that we're in a
fundamentally different
place and catherine's just spoken very
eloquently to that james
um so is where we are now fine it's
great
and and the relationship between matt at
the nhs
uh your successor colleagues at the
department of health
and care but also at the treasury
crucially and the catherines and the
teens of this world
that's all fine or in terms of r d to
end use manufacture there are still
things that we need to do
you you use that example from aviation i
was thinking of the tilting train in the
in in the 80s is another
another example of something which was
actually ahead of its time but which we
never
completed and we now have to buy them
from elsewhere um
and the truth is it's always a work in
progress right but just think about
the vaccines that we are now getting on
stream
and the different types of company or
organization that have been involved you
have
government-funded basic research taking
place
in privately run but charitable
universities
the venture capital and private equity
sector not so much involved in the
oxford vaccine but certainly involved
in the bioentech fisa vaccine supporting
the growth of a biotech
that then works with a larger big
pharmaceutical organization that has the
marketing clout and knows how to
manufacture
that then works with private logistics
companies that comes back to a publicly
funded health care system
that is regulated by government agencies
this
involves everyone you cannot do this
but certainly not at the speed at which
we have done you know and it is an
amazing achievement to have made these
vaccines and any other things in
less than a year you cannot do these
things without
every single link of the chain and so
it's really important not to be
ideological about or private or public
everyone has a role to play and they
have different roles and the point is
that they need to work in partnership
and actually i do think that and we have
unders
we have understood that and i think the
public have probably got a chance to
understand that better
as a result of the crisis i've
definitely seen it
in action all parties around the table
particularly ramping up testing for
example which is another good example it
involved everybody from
you know nhs hospitals to amazon to you
name it uh
in between um to make that happen
um and so it's about locking in that
kind of partnership
and also i think critically really
critically this only works
where everybody is agreed on the
clinical need
this works when there is a strong signal
from the health care system the nhs that
we value
improvements in the delivery of care in
x or y
and if there is a strong signal that
goes out just as obviously it has done
with covid
then everyone knows what they need to be
partnering around and then as matt said
you can
change you can flex you can look at the
different arrangements
as tina says you can look at health data
and how we can get that in and make that
usable
apply ai and use all those resources
that sit in the research sector but
getting clarity about what our
priorities are is the most important
thing
matt the other key thing that flows from
what james is just saying there is
public trust
whether it's purchasing pbe or contracts
this the perception
of deals being done with mates and so on
we talked about that
in in one of the earlier sessions it
seems to me it's equally important just
as much for catherine and and tina
as it is for you and and and ministers
to have
total transparency in all of this that's
quite tricky for people like tina who
are dealing with
very complex clever commercial notions
on data
and catherine running a business that's
there to to do better than
that its competitors i mean how do you
as i've used the expression twice now
as ringmaster make sure that both sides
of the estate are happy
uh i wouldn't call myself a remaster but
uh no i think you're called
[Laughter]
so trust is absolutely absolutely
essential i mean
um only you know the accelerated access
club is hosted by nhs england and it's
improvement
and we have extremely rigorous and
robust processes for spending
any money whatsoever um i report
directly into the chief commercial
officer
um as well as as well as lord darzi on
the aac board and
uh and to under secretary of state as
well so we have a significant oversight
of absolutely
everything we do and but i think they
the key point is actually making sure
that
we are getting um we are a clinically
led
uh and making sure that we can explain
what we're doing to people
more clearly because i think that's
probably one area that we could we could
certainly improve over the last uh
last year or two okay okay fine so we
reckon there then
that there is a new relationship it's
evolved as james shawnee pointed out
it's
it's in a pretty good state catherine
said it was
as good as it has ever been uh and tina
pointed out that there was still a lot
of work to be done
uh matt doesn't like being called a ring
master but but then spoke very
eloquently to
uh in effect prove that that was kind of
partly what his relationship
with both sides were so i'm very happy
with that
um i'm going to change the subject now
or move it on as it were
and don't forget that you can send your
own questions in if we're not covering
something that you feel you want covered
uh either by doing it at the bottom of
the screen uh or by sending an email to
events spectator dot co dot uk but i
want to come to
you tina with this and it's um it's not
a cheap journalistic dig
um it's a it's a factual observation
when dominic cummings was still at
number 10
uh artificial intelligence your daily
bread your meat and drink was
at the pounding heart of government
dominic's now gone and there's a sense
that that that may prove to
uh be tricky it may even be an issue in
the brexit talks about level playing
field and so on and so forth
do you sense that that working
with artificial intelligence and
unleashing something that many ministers
maybe don't completely have their head
around
is going to be more difficult going
forward now that cummings has gone
i don't think it'll be more difficult on
that than he's gone but i
i completely agree with your point about
getting people's head around it
because it's you know i think that's
almost the biggest challenge that we
have
and what i find in my dealings as i work
in public sector private sector
government it is really difficult to
keep up to date with what is going on
regulation's always going to be a step
behind and i think really communicating
and i would say actually making sure
we're
looking at the right problem to find a
solution for
is often the biggest biggest and most
important challenge
so i think in all my work because
everyone works in silos and i think
part of the challenge that we must face
and do
and i think covet has been a fantastic
opportunity to do that is to
go outside our silos focus on the real
problems so obviously we had a pandemic
to deal with
so we brought we brought ourselves
together as a nation everyone just had
to it was all
all guns on deck and the acceleration
the speed with which we have
developed digital uh solutions you know
um you know
sort of virtual uh virtual clinics etc
you know this this was a good thing that
came out of the crisis because everyone
was all hands on deck we have to come up
with some pretty rapid solutions to save
lives
and i think we need that same urgency
and speed
to address the real problem that we have
which is
lancet calls it a syndemic and we've got
a chronic disease
epidemic which is a real problem
we have to reduce demand and the way
that you do that is you you have to
attack it at source you have to keep you
have to deal with prevention
so i think these are some of the bigger
challenges that we've got and going back
to the
ai question i think yes we have to
understand the implications of ai and
this is why i think that
the citizen is so important to be
brought into this debate you know
all of us you know whatever role we play
as business
leaders and government as a citizen we
all have to
understand the implications and
opportunities of this technology and
i'll just mention one thing
in the eu places like estonia and
finland you know they
they actually make a point of educating
their citizens on the role and potential
of the ai
to to you know to get them up the
learning curve i think we have to do the
same so health education
england are looking at this in a much
wider health information digital
literacy program
which by the way my book is is being
made available free from
as part of the reason for that
absolutely
let me bring that in um because i again
i mentioned coming it's not a cheap
journalistic point and actually tina
addressed it
that that so long as ministers and
senior civil servants and think tanks in
government can keep up with this stuff
the door is a jar and and and there is
an appetite for it
um it seems to me though matt that that
this issue needs to be addressed as well
and that is ai
is essentially about big data as tina
made clear
one of the weaknesses over the last nine
months has been
data and the argument between various
virologists and what have you
uh on on the stuff that valance and
witty have been putting up
uh and and predictive graphs or worst
case scenarios and the rest of it
if we're going to be working with a i
and mega mega data
in the evolution of uh of uh
new viruses and the rest of it uh
government either needs to
get a clearer handle on how to use
dictator or butt out
and leave it to the tina's and
catherine's of this world what's your
view
so um uh government uh i think it's
about getting getting the balance right
really
so we've got really strong ministerial
work including
um including work that we're doing on ai
we've um benefited historically from
um actually quite a long line of um
ministers who are really interested in
health health technology
and so they're they're it's going to
remain very high on mrs
minister's minister's agenda and i don't
think that the nhs can console it all um
i think that actually
we do need to work together to work
through some of these issues and i think
as the regulation
develops it's not going to be something
that's developed by the regulators alone
we need to talk about
we do understand the data and do
understand the limitations
um as well so yeah i think it's going to
be an emerging picture but um this is
not something that uh is going to go
away and the nhs is completely uh
committed to uh to continuing that as as
our ministers
but did you sense before i bring
catherine in that that
as it were in the public's mind and that
does matter because you you know whether
you're a big commercial operation
um or whether you're a government
department or something like the nhs you
need to be able to take the public with
you and if
the government is to say that we're
going to be working with people like
tina who's going to be working with
people like catherine
in the evolution of the next family of
of um
of vaccines the public need to have
confidence in that
and therefore they need also to have
total confidence in the data that the
nhs
and its partners use they do they do and
i think that part of the work that we're
doing with the ai and health and care
award is to further test some of these
technologies and evaluate them uh
thoroughly to check
do these technologies work when you put
them into the nhs
so they may work in other systems or the
artificial intelligence may be trained
on other other data sets
so part of particularly for the uh
earlier products earlier in their
in their developments uh do they work in
the nhl
that's a key question that does need to
be answered but i think one of the
things that i consider sort of success
for our work is actually
i want the public to be demanding these
technologies
okay fine catherine are you comfortable
with that um
in the sense of the balance between uh
people like yourselves at
msd and uh and people like tina
uh and what matters just said about the
role that government needs to
uh the nhs rather needs to do and and
james shaunicy's point about having to
keep up are you
are you content with that balance post
comings
absolutely i mean i think it's been
reflected already that we each have to
play to
our strengths and no one individual
party so to speak
has the strengths that are needed to be
able to
to tackle the challenge that we still
have ahead of us so i think playing to
those strengths is critical
where it comes to public confidence you
know we have the opportunity with the
refresh and publication of the uk
vaccine strategy coming out hopefully
to demonstrate that there are different
parts of the system
and that can contribute to this and to
help grow that public confidence in
vaccines
we we shouldn't take for granted and be
complacent
about the level of misinformation and
the confidence that we believe we have
already in the uk which
is in a good place but i think what we
have seen this year
is an increase in sharing of that
misinformation and i think it's really
critically important
that we continue collaboratively to
drive that confidence and make sure that
the public
have the right information so that we
can build on that trust that you
referenced alistair
james that's an absolutely amazing
observation that catherine's just made
which which as it happens i completely
agree with
that that post covert 19 something quite
fundamental
uh has changed um and artificial
intelligence requires huge public faith
and and what's changed is this that the
nhs
the love of the taxpaying british public
for the nhs was always an absolute given
whereas big pharma big companies
profit making return on capital et
cetera et cetera and people like tina
dreaming the impossible dream in the
world of
of high sharp edge science and what have
you was
not as trusted as it seems now to be
that is a huge and fundamental step
forward for the uk
it it certainly is i mean and it is
worth reflecting that even before the
crisis the nhs was the single most
trusted institution in the country when
it came to looking after people's
confidential data
which is you know which is something to
both hold on to and but also to make the
most of
and i think the point that here is is
two things firstly on the data side
we need chance of transparency about how
data is used of course and we need
public
participation in making decisions about
it they need to feel and want to feel
more
involved but so long as the nhs is at
the kind of
vanguard that of these partnerships that
we've
been discussing then people are inclined
to trust them
they understand that you need everybody
to be involved and we've shown that and
we've discussed that this morning
but they really do want this trusted
entity that the closest thing we have to
a religion
in england uh a as nigel lawson i think
said
they want that at the tip of the spear
because that is what kind of embodies
the values if you like
that we all ascribe to so long as that
is true and there is a good value
proposition from these partnerships so
they can see the benefits whether that's
digital
gp gp appointments remote monitoring at
home new vaccines whatever it is
they're absolutely on board so long as
they think that the guardian of the
flame is
is still the nhs intriguing
tina do you need as it were the the seal
of approval of the nhs for the kind of
cutting-edge stuff that
that you've talked about already this
morning
you can go so far because you're a
brilliant businesswoman
but you can go a whole lot further if
you've got as it were the nhs stamp
of approval that james just talked about
i think i mean i completely agree with
everything that
james just said but i think the heart of
this is trust it's trust
in in all of our stakeholders you know
um
and and i think that's a fundamental
question and that's what we
are most at risk of losing actually
result as a result of the pandemic is
this issue of trust so i think we have
to share very very carefully i think the
nhs
as jane said you know has an incredibly
trusted brand
and the values associated with so i
think that's really really important but
i think that the challenge that we've
got
is that the nhs cannot solve the
nation's health on its own
we need it it's going to take a massive
collaborative effort and what
i what i see is encouraging is that
because of the pandemic
there has been quite a sea change in how
you know you look at you know the
business response for example throughout
the pandemic and
the antibodies that tend to exist in
with private sector investment in the
nhs
i think for a time and maybe dissipate
it because you know it's all hands on
deck and i think
we need to continue and build that trust
and i think the way that you do it is
you focus
um around it's it's it's a mission-based
approach and that's what what
and and james will know this this is
what we've we've done quite a lot of
with our all-party parliamentary work
you know it's a collaboration between
academia business government
working together to solve big problems
um but i think at the heart is is
keeping
citizen trust that is absolutely
essential is the bedrock of everything
so we cannot jeopardize that
uh cheeky question catherine
do you feel in a better uh as it were
safer place in in in the public's
affections
as a result of of what we've talked
about thus far
i think you're always going to get a
spread of
um a's perceptions and thought aren't
you across any given population
and in some ways i think this year has
been
a great opportunity to educate people
about vaccines and the incredible
intervention that they
are in terms of the world's public
health that said
not naive enough to and think that there
are people
within the community who still don't
believe that message and
and i guess you know that's the job that
we've all got to do is to help people
appreciate and understand exactly what
it is that they can receive and the
value of vaccines to the entire
population and the role that they play
in public health
um i've got a couple of things that that
that i want to
to finish on because we're we we've got
about 15 minutes left
um but the other thing that's changed
quite fundamentally catherine
is the relationship of of big companies
like yours msd
but also astrazeneca fisa a range of
of big well-known brands in this sector
with with the universities now two
things have happened which
strike me as being quite interesting for
all of you one is the evolution of
business parks outside great
universities
quite often built on their um mba units
and
like warwick and but but and also oxford
and cambridge been doing it for ages and
so on
but the role of the university not only
as being a seat of great learning and
research what have you
but as being a part of that science
commercial community
has evolved very sharply and both sides
have gained from it have they not your
thoughts
catherine i think we have always worked
with universities and as a science like
company
believe that the uk is an attractive
place to do research
and we have partnered as an organization
with some of the large universities
across the uk
for a number of years now i guess like
many things what the pandemic has done
this year has
brought that to the force so that there
is a wider awareness of those
partnerships that
companies like msd and other
pharmaceutical organizations
are doing in the background as an
example we're investing in a new
state-of-the-art discovery research
center in central london
and and that is very much part of you
know our global thinking that the uk
is an attractive place to be and and
part of that belief that
we continue not just start but we
continue to invest in science and
clinical research
yeah and and matt it's
part and parcel because i mean the nhs
some of the trusts are you know
university college hospital blah blah
blah blah
but it seem am i being naive or am i
right that that relationship between
the academic side not only the medical
schools but but at universities
generally and
return on working capital operations
commercial operations
has evolved uh to to collective benefit
collective advantage
oh it's it's it certainly has it
certainly has um so i think on on
research
in particular one of the things one of
the the impacts of the pandemic is that
the non-covered research has slowed down
in the uk so this is a
major for ourselves at nhs and lectures
improvement
but also with colleagues at the
department of health and social care and
the national institute health research
who are working on
um a range of a range of things to uh to
help accelerate the non-coveted research
but in terms of the interface between
academia and industry and that that
really has changed so we've worked with
the department of health social care to
um
create a new designation for academic
health science centers so these are sort
of the
leading hospital and university uh
partnerships
um that have demonstrated um excellence
in health research
excellent in patient excellence and
patient care and um
excellence in health education so really
bringing together those different
different assets
and actually sort of supporting that
translation of these technologies
from uh from bench to bedside
intriguing and james bring that all
together for me as i say because
uh you you you sat in on all of this you
were
your fingerprints were over the
evolution of it and in the same way we
had
the pleasure of paul burster's company
before the break talking about
his experience as a minister in the care
sector now out of it and more in the
think tank bit like you
but as far as our great universities are
concerned and yeah we everybody knows
about oxford and
and astrozenica but there's also down
the road from where i live southampton
have been doing
uh amazing work reading university have
been up all sorts of them have been at
it and there's catherine saying
this relationship is a it is an
evolution a refinement and development
of it
um does it sit up there with you as well
as the nhs giving the stamp of approval
that that relationship between the
universities and the
commercial sector is it that important
you're right and so it's incredibly
important we have brilliant research
universities that's a given
um the uk has unfortunately been a bit
slow
on the commercialization spin-out
scene we are getting there now at
university level with these so-called
tech transfer offices that most of the
big research universities
will have them the truth is we are still
a bit slow on this in the nhs so let me
give you a comparison
um of a country we should certainly be
seeking to emulate which is not the us
but israel
so israel is a you know much smaller
country about eight million people
but they have their four health care
systems and about eight to ten of their
large hospitals
have their own tech transfer offices not
related to a university
but their own tech transfer offices and
that are actually generating new ideas
and then working with a range of
partners academic commercial
and other and venture capitalists
another to create new
businesses that can both support and
improve the performance of a given
hospital or healthcare system but then
obviously have
products that go out around the world we
don't yet have anything quite like that
we do in individual instances but we
don't systemically
across the country and so i think that
is a massive opportunity for us because
no one doubts that we have the ability
to do it
we have the clinicians who are capable
if they can find the time i think this
is quite an important part as we
recover from kovid we don't want to
squeeze
all the time that's currently devoted as
matt was saying
to research on covid out in in a bid to
get
on top of waiting lists and so on we
need to continue this very pro-research
culture
which we've actually had over the last
nine months but also
as i say to connect that to the
commercial expertise and the spin-out
capacities that some of these
universities have in other fields like
engineering
and apply that to healthcare and that
will be that will give us a new stream
of amazing biotech
ai and other health care companies for
years ahead
i'm grateful to all of you thank you
very much indeed all that remains for me
to say
is again another big thank you to msd
who were our sponsors and uh made this
possible
uh and to all of my panelists as well
for uh committing a morning
to conversation a conversation i hope
you uh
found useful uh and found as optimistic
as did i
but for the time being and until next
time a very good morning to you bye-bye
[Music]
you